faz fala de 8 na escala do índice vai
dar dinheiro pra casa em dia
e aí galera que assistiu à final tudo
bom você esses dias eu estava no meu
twitter meu twitter é esse aqui se você
quiser me seguir você vai lá e segue
rapidão aí você me segue lá você nunca
perdeu o vídeo nem eu recebi uma
pergunta e eu não sei por que eu não sei
por que as pessoas tenham esse tipo de
coisa eu tenho cara de drauzio varella
do amor à pergunta eu fui do que as
mulheres gostam que que as mulheres
gostam para você fez essa pergunta pra
mim já começando esse vídeo quero
explicar uma coisa mulher ela é que nem
impresso ou digital você pode até achar
uma que seja parecida com a outra mas
ela nunca nunca nunca vai ser igual
não importa você pode saber de todos os
segredos das mulheres se pode saber tudo
você pode ser [ __ ] na arte da sedução
você pode ser um milionário pode ser
carinhoso atencioso unidos e pode ser
tudo mas vai chegar um dia em que você
vai querer um mulher que vai falar tudo
isso que você é para ela eu comecei a
falar assim for vai sair cara bruto um
cara [ __ ] cara que não é carinhoso
porquê porque ela gosta disso você sabe
disso não você sabe se assim não saiba
você pode saber de muito você pode até
sabendo que as mulheres bloco mas não
era de nenhuma que vai conseguir pegar
qualquer momento quis a dica é essencial
para você saber o que é que a menina
gosta é seja igual ela mas como assim
como é ser que eu seja seja igual a essa
entendeu não vou explicar afinal minha
net revela a hora do recreio ainda
universidade gama usam silvia luna
chupar bagaça negado essa daí se peida
pode capturar e pesquisar a fazer nova
fragrância da gente como é que faz para
se aproximar de uma pessoa tem que ser
igual a ela tem que gostar daquilo que
ela gosta ela gosta de ouvir
los hermanos vai ter que ouvir los
hermanos e não estou falando para vocês
se você é roqueiro metaleiro semana de
samba se você goste regra estou falando
com você deixar o seu estilo deixar sua
banda preferida para ouvir até não tô
falando para você aprender a gostar do
que ela gosta você gosta do que a pessoa
que você tem assunto para conversar você
tem coisas em comum e jael já um ponta
foi a falar ó a pessoa tá lá a aula é
aquilo é que é
você tá ouvindo que a oi oi está
escutando ela é que alguns que saiu nova
em bom lançamento aqui tá rolando asbac
do acre a aula é que caia libertar a
história a nossa aqui porque a lbv
veículso fãs scarpetta com a kl b que eu
só que faltou tinta no caso do dia da
toalha fique legal e aí vai começar um
conversa você vai começar por aí você se
aproximou da pessoa mulher gosta disso
mulher gosta do homem que gosta daquilo
que ela gostou que o segundo passo de
ser igual a ela que você talvez ainda
não sabe como é que você vai fazer a
menina gosta de você você é um minério
caso sequer uma menina no caso não é
sexual por a mulher ela é verdade ela
fala ela fala para o sexo oposto à
verdade o cara tiver pela falta feita ou
botar um erro fatal ruim pra mim não pra
mim ela já pode mentir não tamanho
quintal mas para o cara não se tiver
feito a música fala sobre o uso está
muito boa não você tem que ser
verdadeiro igual a ela se ela colocar
uma roupa feia na sua frente fala tá
feia mas como assim eu estou gostando da
minha eu eu tô num momento em que eu
tenho que elogiar a ela é aqui que está
o diferencial de você
nos outros carros e vai ser mais
apertada do que todos os outros caras
tentaram pegar ela e todos os que vão
tentar pegar o outro falar que eu vou
poder estar bonita porque a mulher não é
burro não era começar eu sempre falei
'se tiver feira eu falo que é outro
passo que as mulheres dottie outro passo
a seguir este atenção nos detalhes como
homem ele no geral e não tem a
capacidade de pensar nos detalhes e
olhar os detalhes o que a gente a gente
meio que tem um book e esse aqui vai ser
o nosso ponto positivo todos os outros
nomes no olho nos detalhes
a gente olha eu falei o homem geral ele
tem mas que tem um bloqueio que não
consegue estar pensando de tapume fábio
mulher e fala da bunda dela ele fala dos
peitos dela fala meu irmão ontem vi uma
gata mas é uma gata hotel mabu ó o outro
fala meu irmão o teu houve uma gata
irmão aquele respeito à liga não
abastecer uma cidade todinha com leite
agora você nunca nunca vai achar um
homem que vai dizer sim mão o que eu vi
uma gata que tal com francesinha na um é
caô uti fica assim o acabamento feitinho
se pode ela tira uma retoma assim está
nunca nunca você nunca vai achar um cara
que faz é só prestar atenção nos
detalhes e o pior é que não precisa de
muito você chega na casa da amiga você
gosta você apoia dela de gol assim só
olha memoriza citá pintado ou não se
tiver pintada e memoriza qual é a cor
que está pintado preciso saber o nome da
coroa só memorizam a cortar pintar se
não tiver quitado e também melhorias que
não está a contar e se for lá outro na
próxima vez que você for lá cada - e web
ou discretamente ela mudou a cor do
esmalte já se conhecem você está usando
e não aqui ou na outra vez que eu vim
aqui ele estava de tal coisa agora está
a ciência bonito tal mão você subir 1
mil level no game da vida dessa menina
porque você prestar atenção numa coisa
que os outros querem pegar ela nunca
baixar a tsu então você é diferente dos
outros
a outra coisa que a mulher gosta deixo
você e você tem que ter um beijo
perfeito você foi embora se você prestar
atenção se você for verdadeiro você não
souber beijasse vai ficar atrás porque
os outros cartão e beijando está ligado
não tem cabo e dá até nome não é que
você vai fazer pra beijar bem foi a
fórmula pra beijar bem lembra o que eu
falei lá no começo desse vídeo você tem
que ser igual a ela você veja bem uma
pessoa que você tem que beijar e glória
porque não tem ninguém no mundo que não
é que o seu próprio mês e beija kelly
slater e me pronto quem gosta não gostou
nem assim se faz mas ela gosta de beijar
ela veio devagar deixa de falar ela
beija molhado beijo mas ela gosta de
beijar ela gosta de passar a mão em você
não gosta de beijar pegar poderiam pegar
basta a moeda passa a mão na bunda dela
pega com força sensata porque ela pela
cintura se eu passar no cabelo igual a
ela caso seja igual a ela vai falar com
sintomas do prefeito é assim um
pouquinho em pouquinho né fora vou dar
perfil nem os carros outros caras por lá
beijo na mão ele é melhor você não está
fechando um é disso que ainda gosta você
pegar você quiser um resumo desse vídeo
toda a gente vai parar para pensar
não é tudo isso falou é neguei é gay é
gay pra ver se você acha o game desculpa
mas deu muito certo pra a vida inteira
eu quero que tudo comece aqui em baixo o
que foi domingo fez com que tu mais
odiou e o que tu mais gostoso para
deixar que ele jogue fora não te dá a
dica que eu te ajudar tudo sai daqui do
blog do vídeo basta um clique gostei é
foto então clique em gostei pra nós que
está ajudando a cada
se a primeira vez que você tá aqui
assistindo esse vídeo aqui você clica em
inscrever se dá uma olhada no canal
achei de vídeo legal e tem uns 70 vídeos
clique no escrever toda vez que tiver
veloso é saber se segue no twitter que
está aqui na descrição do vídeo segue
também no facebook e instagram para
quando tiver de novo vou sempre falar
nessas redes sociais não tem como você
fica sem saber se fica sem saber por que
eu citava semana o mercado então é isso
espero que eu tenho nada a vocês e é
isso aí porque eu não gostei comenta
aqui embaixo e inscrever-se segue nas
redes sociais de ninguém
[Música]